فرح زمان شوقي متواجده في انقره اللي
تطلعنا على اخر النتائج التي لديكم مما
يتعلق بانقره ووتيره فرز الاصوات في هذه
المنطقه المهمه انتخابيا خاصه على صعيد
مقاعد البرلمان فرح زمان
في الحقيقه جلال حتى وان كان فرز الاصوات
الخاصه بالانتخابات الرئاسيه اسرع بكثير
من فرز الاصوات المتعلق بالانتخابات
البرلمانيه انقره تعتبر مدينه حاسمه في
الحقيقه بسبب هويتها ورمزيتها ورسائلها
السياسيه وايضا تركيز المعارضه التركيه
عليها وتحديدا حزب الشعب الجمهوري على
مساله استعادتها سواء في البرلمان او في
منصب رئاسه الجمهوريه جلال اخر
التصريحات التي صدرت من هذا المقر كانت لي
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول وانقره والتي تحدث
فيها عن ضروره اعتماد النتائج الاوليه
محددين هنا وكاله واسمها وكاله انكا وهي
المحسوبه على المعارضه في الوقت الذي
تعتمد فيه النتائج الاوليه من وكاله رسميه
ثانيه لذلك هنالك تشكيك حقيقه في في هذه
المساله لكن اكرم رئيس بلديه اسطنبول تحدث
صراحه وقال ان في النهايه صندوق الاقتراع
هو الذي يتحدث وهو الذي سيحكم في اشاره
منه الى قبول هذه النتائج ربما الحديث هنا
عن احتمال اكبر الان للذهاب الى جوله
ثانيه خاصه ان الحديث داخل حزب الشعب
الجمهوري المعارض يتحدث عن نسب اقل من 50%
وتقارب في نسب الاصوات التي ذهبت لكل من
كل جدار اوغلو واردوغان والفارق بينهما
نقاط بسيطه سواء في العديد من المناطق في
الحقيقه ومن بينها ايضا مدينه